welcome back to new rock stars the new
eternals trailer finally awakens the
god-like protectors of earth after
apparently snoozing or sitting out of
every mcu crisis but why now are they
entering the chat what new threat is
dragging them out of obscurity
or are they really the friends who just
show up to help you move only after all
the big stuff is unloaded but
still take the biggest slices of pizza
this is rogue theory it's a show where
we pitch the wildest theories for the
movies we love i'm eric boss going broke
with me today is a panel i'm so excited
about we got mt here hey mt
hey what's going on eric oh man it's
gonna be so good it's gonna be so good
man
it's gonna be good we got jessica
clements back on the show
hi and yes we're thrilled to welcome to
new rockstars comedian and host of the
blurts in the hood show
jay washington welcome james oh man i
feel like i made it i've been trying to
get here for the longest
and it's like i just want to make sure
i'm good i clean my fingernails i think
like i want to make sure they see me i
don't want people zooming in on my nails
in the video be like look at these
cuticles
i've been like why are you playing this
my cuticles
enhance now put your fingernails up to
your camera
right this second but no i'm happy to be
here seriously i'm excited to talk about
this and the subject
because i'm one of the eight people i
know total in the world that was like
yeah this could be
fun i'm like eight people bro
wow three of the eight of them are in
this one video yes
[Laughter]
you'll have to guess which three i mean
that's what i love about eternals is
like
all of us on youtube right now are like
yeah okay so here
this is what the turtles are about all
of us are like wait wait who are the
attorneys
because the eternals despite like what
some of us sound like we're
talking confidently we're all kind of
playing catch up be like because they're
not one of the bigger names yeah
they're not super popular so it's easy
to like sort of forget those eternal
details but you got to know the weird
stuff
i think that's the thing people forget
marvel i always say this
when marvels did marvel days guardians
of the galaxy they proved they could do
whatever they wanted
because you asked 95 of comic book fans
of comic book movie fans
they had no idea who the guardians were
unless they watched this ultimate
spider-man cartoon
and so when they were able to make you
love a talking raccoon and a talking
tree
the fact you hear about people who've
been around since almost the beginning
of time
and now you're like oh yes angelina
jolie i'm here for it let's go
exactly i'm here great point jay exactly
and i think the question we're now
asking is kind of that question now in
the mcu is like
why the eternals returning now in
particular where
like we can ask where they've been but
like there's this interesting um uh
description
that they're putting out for the movie
it's official from marvel saying after
an unexpected tragedy following the
events of avengers endgame
the eternals an immortal alien race
created by the celestials
who have secretly lived on earth for
over seven thousand years reunite to
protect humanity from their evil
counterparts the deviants
but like how do the deviants come back
if that's the case what is this
unexpected tragedy
and what has kept them from intervening
in all these previous mcu crises
yeah go ahead and go for it so again
i've been rereading
my eternals dreaming celestial saga like
this is 400 some pages
and then i have the cause of gorgeous
i've been rereading these for a while i
read them a long time ago
so what it is i've had this theory for
the longest the snap so they are
they're dormant as to them being eternal
in their minds right
sprite who's played by leah mchugh is
gonna make them dormant
after four snaps remember it's four
snaps total
the initial snap thanos does in infinity
war the second snap he does to get rid
of the stones
the third snap that uh hulk does to
bring everybody back
and the fourth snap that iron man does
all four of those snaps as rockets said
releases a bunch of cosmic energy
that lets the celestials possibly know
to come back
who else is a celestial galactus who
else does he wake up instead of the
eternals
the deviants who've been living below
the earth so everybody wakes up
and all of a sudden sprite is the only
one that even though she's a kid
she still knows kind of who she is
icarus has a clue
but spritel started waking more than
likely everybody up
and again it's like now as they said
phase four and five we're going more
cosmic and quantum
with everything so now what's this
bigger threat a celestial
the the two the celestials that made the
eternals humanity and the devious
and then again galactus is an eternal i
mean a celestial
as well as ego living planet but he
hella dead so it's like yeah
yeah i think that's i mean that seems
like the
the the way to go right is the snap just
affects all these things and we saw how
cool it was when one division revisited
the moment where everyone kind of
reaperated from the snap
might have been dusted you know and how
that affected all of them
but for sure like bringing in galactus
and this like
this is such a prime opportunity to
bring galactus into the mcm
you know i agree with jay i think that's
a great way for them to come in it makes
the most sense uh
and but also i disagree if i can have a
t-shirt that says i disagree all right
um but i'm bringing in the trouble so
i think i think that what i know that in
the comics that was crow that kind of
was like we're gonna turn humans on each
other so that
the uh the celestials can see that
humans are just garbage
uh but i think druid is actually gonna
be trying to do something like that and
he's gonna be the one that's starting
the chaos and that's when
we see sprite i think sprite did have
everyone lay dormant
and sprite's gonna sprite has been so i
think sprite is still doing that like
like the neil gaiman like still doing tv
and being like
crazy and fancy but i think that's also
doing it
with uh camille's character too so i
think both of them are aware
that they are eternals but the other
eternals are still dormant and they
don't want to wake them up because they
don't want to get back to doing what the
eternals are supposed to be doing
but when juric starts with all the
humans and the celestials come in
that's when they're like we can't do
this on our own we have to go wake up
everyone else
and i think that's when we see that
scene of the volcano erupting and the
clouds going dark and the light shooting
up those are the celestials showing up
in different parts of the world
and i think that's where we see um
surtsey and
black knight hanging out together
because they're dating i think when we
saw
that's a boy toy that's not dayton
that's cersei's
love it either boys but i think when she
hey i'm here for boy toys
but i think when she um when we saw her
walking
and uh what was i thinking was ancient
babylon but also in the same jacket she
was wearing in new york
i think that was cersei coming too i
think she's in new york but she's
remembering i used to walk these streets
i'm certsie like the eternal and i think
that's why we're seeing like
her with black knight now present
because
none of and that's what the celestials
are coming through with the cloud
i hope that makes sense but i think yeah
i know what's happening
all those scenes were seen in the
trailer are just flashbacks of their
minds when they were like
because they're like oh i'm dormant
right now i'm just a normal human i
think it's like those are the clips that
we're seeing it's them i just have these
weird-ass dreams i don't know why
i think icarus and cersei's like little
love thing little love thing i think
that's just icarus
flashbacks when he's coming too i think
he's like oh
[Laughter]
yeah and to be clear to anybody who
might be confused when we're talking
dormant we're not talking like literally
asleep
it's like your mind you just forget your
past
and you're just kind of a walking husk
of what you were just living your life
without a care in the world and then now
suddenly all those
previously blacked out memories like
he's like oh yeah oh
i'm actually married oh crap like i'm
married to the other stark brother
wrong
like brian tyree henry's character
fastos he's the greatest builder
ever he's the greatest and he builds all
weapons and everything and he
one of the things is in the comics he
didn't want to do it no more he was like
yo i'm trying to live this life
and they're making a big thing with this
here in the movie because
he's openly gay in the movie now so
we're going to see
a man living a normal life you know
literally a normal life a gay man but
you know somebody in there is gonna be
like
how dare they do this to even like shut
up
but like i think it's when he's woken up
it's like we need you to do
what you're good at you know you make
these weapons we need to stop things and
he doesn't want to do that
and so that's the beautiful thing and
then it also ties into people i keep
talking about
the inhumans but for me it ties into the
this is going to start the mutants
this is the mutants jump off for sure
for sure
i agree yeah with that freaking sorry
real oh which we can talk about later
but i want to put a freaking stake in
the ground about it right now
when we're seeing in the trailer uh
mainly your breakdown voss about all of
the older
um captain america shields and how we're
seeing them
two theories hey i think kumail's
character since in the comics he was
just a really big fan of samurai so he
made himself a samurai i think he's just
loves the avengers so he just wanted to
like own memorabilia of captain america
but two i think there's also a
possibility athena created those
instead of uh because thena did create
she was in the neil gaiman
comics she was like creating for stark
like she was
on loan for stark business and making
weapons like she could have
but i know that ties in too much to like
well stark's dad created it and it's
like yeah but like
this woman's been alive forever maybe
she sparked an idea in him
and then it came into that yeah i mean
created or discovered
you know like discovered something that
was already there we're all standing on
the shoulders of someone else
do you think that athena's love is gonna
set all this off too
because athena's in love with crow who's
a deviant
i want it that's what i'm seeing
i don't think it's gonna happen also
because angelina okay so as like
i want it so bad i need because i love
that connection with the deviants
i needed it um but i also think this is
angelina jolie playing thena
in the mcu and i think she's going to be
like
not to tie it into that but right now
she's like i don't need a man i don't
need a partner i want to be a strong
symbol for like women in the army i want
to be like i needed to be billy bob
thornton's crow
i think she's gonna do everything so
independently and be kind of just like
whatever
hey she could be that you just talk
about boy toys right she can be an
independent woman and still have her
i'm true saying she's strong and she
don't need a man or d exactly
in the trailer she kind of feels like
she's like struggling with something
like like as soon as she cuts those like
green ribbons she looks like she's sad
or lovely
exactly
we're getting a baby him we're getting a
baby thanos because of it
for sure you're getting the baby for
people who don't know
a large azure the brothers who one is
the dad of thanos goes to saturn
and makes you know goes to saturday in
the titan moves the titan meets his mama
and has his little
glass purple baby who just is really mad
because he like why am i purple
and like he just because he he shouldn't
be perfect
it's gonna be a dinosaur in a thousand
some years like this is [ __ ]
i don't want to be this way
well empty i want to hear from you
what's your theory for how like uh
how what kept the eternals it like
unaware
and what is now why now are they joining
the mcu one of the main reasons why the
eternals are
are activating now is because you know
sort of similar to what you know jay was
talking about earlier
it's because of these these snaps that
were happening
on earth and you know if it was just one
snap it'd be whatever but there was
three snaps
on marvel earth and that is a big deal
and if you remember
in um i believe it was avengers when
thor was talking to
nick fury about you know you know why
all the avengers stuff was happening in
avengers 1 he was like
yo you guys are messing with the
tesseract and like when you did that
it sent a signal to everybody in the
world that earth was ready
for a higher form of war and so yeah
this is
the tesseract times six three times so
the
tesseract 18 times and so um
you know this happens and these
celestials are like what's going on over
there
we left those experiments and they're
being crazy over there we gotta go check
that out
and so the eternals are just like oh
[ __ ] like these celestials are coming
back because we've been making too much
noise
and you know because one of the snaps
ended up taking out half of humanity
and therefore you know a ton of their
celestial experiments throughout the
cosmos
they're probably gonna be like earth we
should probably get rid of this
because it's just becoming a problem you
know so you know it's that it's a host
of the celestials that we may
be facing in the eternals movies um
basically the end of the world which is
why the the song and the trailer is like
you know hints at the end of the world i
think that the solutions are coming
to potentially get rid of you know this
human
threat um that is annoying their
experimentations but that's just all
right
i have a question hi mt are you
basically saying
are you saying that the celestials are
going to control all delete the planet
thank you i'll be here all week
[Laughter]
yes the celestials want to control out
delete earth because it's uh
malfunctioning
this isn't a callback or a joke do you
think
we haven't seen it in the trailer but do
you think that the us army are going to
get involved at all with any of this we
haven't seen any actual like normal
human
like involvement to the degree of like
to the degree of like we need to fight
back
but i mean i mean if the celestials end
up do you
end up coming you know what what did the
army do when the chitauri invaded they
tried to throw a nuke at it
and like to to to end their problems so
like with the celestials come in
on their ships it's like oh yeah we're
gonna nuke it and if you remember in the
comics
when the deviants did that like in the
with the third host of celestial the
second i don't know
what uh one of those um the celestials
were like we don't like that and they
started
cataclysm so if the army does get
involved
it probably wouldn't be good because the
celestials are way stronger than the
united states army
are you ready i have a question
oh but my question is empty mary kill
and why am i kill of the other
why am i always killed you're not killed
it's mary bro you gotta kill him
i don't get it
don't sit here and ponder this [ __ ] let
me know you taking me out
you don't have to answer the question
but i i do love that like
this idea of bringing the celestials in
i think they they are kind of the
villain you know like
oh that's why if you're gonna do an
eternal story right like
it seems like you do need the eternals
to face off against a cadre of the
celestials
like that's how you up the ante from the
avengers because otherwise it's just
like well if it's any other kind of
calamity the avengers have been pretty
capable
of handling all kinds of threats cosmic
or earthbound
uh so the only thing that i could see
you needing the eternals for if you're
just talking power status wise
are things like galactus or silver
surfer or celestials you know
what do you guys think what the unimod
is gonna look like because you know
we're getting it
yeah oh yeah i think they teased it in
the trailer um with the flowers
yeah i think it's gonna look fairly
comic accurate i think that you know
because you know we we already have a
brain in the
mcu already with ego ego was basically a
brain he wasn't a person he was a
floating brain yeah so there could be a
tie into that it's like was ego
a unimined in that that's like how when
he flickered on it's like oh i don't
remember
that i used to be people i'm now ego you
know so like
i think we might actually get a brain
because it's there's precedent for it
yeah i don't like to think that the
celestials are evil i don't think they
are evil
did you say i think they're just kind of
neutral they're just
they just don't i think they're neutral
i think they're just the
oldest living things on the planet
they're the gods and they're just like
hey if you guys look like an act crazy
we're gonna have to
calm you down i mean they basically was
like look these are some ape dudes let's
fix them up
they took one it was like well you are
well they're like you normal they got
some others like look at you all
beautiful and blonde hair blue eyed and
dark
so wrong and that's i feel like the
deviants are another pair of like mcu
characters that are just like
oh we'll walk in their shoes they kind
of got sent
underneath the waters to live an
eternity in darkness
and just be ugly just because just
because they're ugly because they are
smart
most of them can talk they are the
deviants are like will smith in that
episode of fresh prince when ben veree
was his daddy
why don't no one want me uncle phil
right now
that
i like how you remembered it was ben
vereem a stage legend ben vereen i'd
never made that connection that that's
who that was
they all just said they really just said
they're like yo we want to be up here
and [ __ ]
y'all got nice sun and it's it's picky
coladas and there's kardashians now we
rather
here honestly i think they might
actually make a case for this in this
movie
like it's not really based on anything
it's just a hunch but like you know we
see
you know killmonger people love a good
you know person fighting for
disenfranchised people
so you know maybe that's what druid is
in this movie maybe he's fighting for
the
for the deviants and in their rights in
the comics i love the d
i love the rejected one um also because
he was really fine
but i understand that's what your love
goes for him like you know what
flight he was fine
[Laughter]
all right uh guys i gotta say this has
been not only the funniest conversation
i've ever had about the eternals i think
it is the most
informed and knowledgeable uh debate
slash discussion about what's gonna
happen in this movie
because i think you're right i think we
do have three of the eight most
knowledgeable
eternal notes on this call right now the
turtles is great
it's so good the stories are just so
deep because it's like it gets if you
when you read it it gets real comic
booky
but you're looking at the stories you're
like oh this is like oh
oh these are heartstrings being cool
like this isn't right
with the with the celestials being
involved in the eternals
there is a chance that we could actually
see you know
apocalypse or a tease of apocalypse or
younger apocalypse
in um in eternals with um celestial
experimentations or something like that
so you know that we could or or even
namor because neymar is the first mutant
in
marvel comics so maybe instead of
apocalypse who's been done before
recently in the x-men franchise and for
fox
we could actually end up seeing you know
the origins of atlantis or something
like that
i see shaking his head
because we never should ever reference
x-men ivan ooze we should never
reference him again
ever
like i've seen cosplays look better than
what the movie studios
yeah yeah they really do need a reboot
of apocalypse you know it's actually
kind of easy that apocalypse was so bad
in the fox x-men franchise because now
marvel gets to do them right whenever
they want to bring in mutants but yeah
hopefully
hopefully in this movie uh i want to
award some points because this is rogue
theory and weirdly i have to reward
points
just based off of whatever uh so jess
i'm giving you one point for uh putting
saul on druid because yeah i think druid
is gonna be
a big part of this uh maybe he is part
he is uh uh
loyal to the deviants i love that idea
for sure
uh mt i'm gonna give you two points or
bring this idea of uh i mean alerting
these celestials
and as jay said a control hold delete
but also saying that like mutants like
uh
like apocalypse could show up for sure
jay i'm gonna give you
three points because
you had this great take of uh of like
the idea of galactus coming in
you uh correctly identified the four
snaps which most people they can't
recall that there's like more than one
or two
uh so that's pretty impressive uh and
yeah just reminding us of the
interesting history
of how uh thanos and how his bloodline
with lars and
suicide and his brother and how he's
connected to that whole genetic history
uh so good job uh to all y'all uh this
was
a great conversation um so we're going
to talk
about uh some interesting questions
around jimmy chan who's playing cersei
uh in this movie in just a second first
we want to thank some friends who helped
us make this
episode uh well quick shout out to our
merch uh you can find at uh
newrockstarsmerch.com we have a great uh
assortment of t-shirts hoodies water
bottles hats
all stuff you need to do if you want to
be an authentic new rockstars
fan i guess you could be a fan without
doing it what am i saying oh i'm sorry
i'm sorry they
had a gun at me right now buy our stuff
please uh
newaxesmerge.com we want to thank
bluetooth for sponsoring this episode
our friends at bluetooth have a unique
online service that delivers the same
active ingredients as viagra
in seattle but in chewable form
at a fraction of the cost what you got
there jake oh my god
it's a blue chew oh is it really
a blue chew oh my god
hey man in my days of working on this
show have i
seen someone present wow he was ready
for the ad
this is the actual appeal
wow this is the flute let me tell you
something
we have a happy customer on the call
is an online prescription service so no
doctor's office or pharmacy trips it
ships right to your door in a discreet
package like what jay just showed us
uh you sign up at bluetooth.com consult
with one of their licensed medical
providers and once you're approved you
receive your prescription within days
their licensed medical providers work
with you to find the right ingredient in
strength and if you hate swallowing
pills good news blue chew is
chewable just like it says in the name
so if you could benefit from some extra
confidence when it's time to perform
visit bluetooth.com for more details
and important safety information and we
got a special deal for our audience try
bluetooth for free when you use our
promo code
rogue at checkout just pay the five
dollars in shipping that's bluetooth.com
promo code rogue to receive your first
month free and we thank bluetooth for
sponsoring this episode
and we want to thank expressvpn for
sponsoring this episode most of us have
very little choice when it comes to
picking our internet service provider
because isps operate
kind of like monopolies in the regions
that they serve they use that power to
take advantage of the customers
and many isps log your internet activity
and they sell that data on other big
tech companies
to advertisers it's a mess so to prevent
isps from seeing my internet activity i
protect all my devices with
expressvpn it's a simple app for your
computer or smartphone that encrypts all
your network data and tunnels it through
a secure vpn server so that your isp
cannot see any of your activity
every site you visit video you watch or
message you send gets tracked by isps or
other tech giants who can then sell your
information for profit and that's the
reason i recommend expressvpn as the
best way to hide your online activity
from isps
download the app tap one button on your
device and you are protected and
expressvpn does all this without slowing
your connection that's why it's rated
the number one vpn service by cnet and
wired so stop handing over your personal
data to isps and other tech giants who
mind your activity and sell up your
information protect yourself with the
vpn i trust to keep me private online
visit expressvpn.com rogue that's exp or
essvpn.comrogue to get three extra
months free go to expressvpn.com
rogue right now to learn more all right
so back to eternals jimmy chan the star
of this movie is playing
cersei after also appearing as the cree
minerva back in captain marvel now
obviously this seems like a case of
marvel studios just recasting an actor
from a smaller mcu role
to a more prominent one and just
assuming fans won't get too hung up on
it
good luck with that uh but it's you
could say this isn't unprecedented laura
haddock played meredith quill after she
had already played a captain america fan
girl
uh back in the 1940s and james gunn has
confirmed that those characters are not
related and soon michelle yo is going to
be in chongqi in the legend of the ten
rings playing uh
after she played elita o'gourd one of
the ravagers in guardians vol 2.
but i want us to go rogue here and
speculate that there could be some
in-universe explanation for jimmy chan
in these dual roles
it is true first um
okay so yeah like vos said i do think
it's not gonna be too crazy i think they
just switched characters but
if they want to go crazy with it what
they can do so let's say
there is a cruel uh scroll scroll sorry
i don't know i said cruel
there's a nick roll there's a scroll
right and it's not a good scroll
and it does take her identity what
better identity than to take than
someone that's an eternal
especially if after this movie we figure
out who like we know gemma chan as
cersei someone takes her identity as
cersei in the future
and is just like not like it's not going
to be like how um
uh shang chi's father it's not gonna be
like oh oh
i'm actually like so and so or like how
people like use him as
just like uh use his character as i
forgot what doppelganger mandarin
yeah yeah yeah yeah like how everyone
was like i'm the mandarin i'm the
mandamere adam the mandarin i don't
think it'll be like that but i think
there are going to be an opportunity
later on in the like
even if it's scroll invasion where
they're just like talking
and they're like i'm cersei's and
they're like oh my gosh yeah cersei we
need to listen to her but it's actually
a squirrel
wait so do you think the member of the
group that we saw in captain marvel the
cree who were like chasing down and
hunting down squirrels do you think
she was a squirrel like mole on that
team
no you have to go crazy with it because
okay realistically in the movie of the
world of hollywood yeah
i don't think it's a crazy one
it's true what do you think cersei likes
to get a party and a freak on
i would not be surprised if cersei bangs
first she rang the creep okay this is
rogue
this is a real girl she has sex cersei
parties
let's be real cersei has been through
years like we don't know how many kids
cersei been out here with that and she
got a
she got an internal elliptical and she
can keep her figure down
she got the best of mineral waters it's
probably just a kid
like again minerva maybe a kid or a
distance
y'all saying go road
that's real i like the mini marauder
joke because of the trailer because she
puts her into the water and the water
comes out and then she immediately
shoves her face in and drinks it
mineral water i have a question for
jay so yeah athena has a child
eventually with a human
so you think that cersei can have sex
with a scroll and it'll be a scroll
no it's a it's a cree what's your name
oh it's a creature
yeah she's blue she has sex with a cree
and a cream may be
because of the light we might find out a
cree is an offshoot of a deviant
okay okay okay so actually it isn't that
rogue it makes complete sense
yeah and actually i'd buy that theory
it's pretty good don't ask me no
questions you know what i'm gonna do
you had some thoughts on this what do
you think so minerva
dies in captain marvel and so i think at
that point at that death
we get a rebirth of of the character of
cersei who
is now done with this life as this you
know jerky cree minerva and minerva
is the name minerva is is greek
or something and like there are roman
names
athena i think yes and so like these are
you know very greeky and like you know
themed characters and in their names is
it roman or greek
i don't know i guess yeah yeah yes but
it's it's the same yeah
yeah same shouldn't be a different era
yeah whatever anyway um so yeah i think
that
this name minerva is significant because
it is you know tied to the eternal
type deal so when she's reborn she's
like oh wait
i was an [ __ ] for my last life i
don't want to do that
and so we get you know that that shot of
her looking around new york like i'm
alive now what's going on
and like you know like that steve rogers
asked like i
you know in a different era now sort of
type deal
i wouldn't ever give my boy
i think this idea of like uh maybe
eternals have different incarnations
that pop up on different planets or
maybe there's like
this is what the so the ten eternals are
assigned to earth right but maybe
these 10 same actors were put in other
places like on holla
on tour on all these other planets in
the mcu
and then that's just like there's a
brian tyree henry walking around with
the other three i'm not
sure you know i don't know that's one
way to go
yeah jessica what do you think i agree
with um i agree with mt
and also just to amplify the theory the
fact that in
i keep going back to the no diamond
comics but in the comics
like the people that are like dormant
they once they die in that form they
come
back as themselves the actual
superheroes
in their plant or i think it was on the
planet or in the ship
yeah okay okay it was in olympia they
come back as themselves
so if she did die as minerva she's
coming back
as cersei so uh not even
a a crazy theory that it's true it could
happen
it's just part of the eternals mythos
really
[Laughter]
bang the creek you guys are listening
i hope the movie starts with those words
i'm gonna give all three of you uh one
point
uh because i think together collectively
we made that make sense
i think honestly yes i do
[Laughter]
uh but well done um all right we have
time for one more question that all
three of you guys are going to answer
this is our our rogue question round
where it's just
where we get real silly as if we haven't
gotten silly enough this has been very
serious up to this point now
but okay so here's our question it was
announced this week that the pym
test kitchen in disney's adventures
campus
uh at disneyland uh will sell a 100
sandwich that's meant to feed six to
eight people called
the pimini wow so the question is what
other ridiculous
marvel inspired food do you want to see
served at avengers campus
the collector it's nothing but all of
the damn lunch meats
ever collected on one bread
it's like what is their capital spouse
and you get a sad order of howard the
duck fries just
oh my god jay's already thought of this
i feel like he's already had plans to
make an avengers franchise of
restaurants
it needs to be on the menu it needs to
be on the menu
a thunderbolt
toss
know what that is a thunderbolt is it an
open ass
just like this
this is quite the meal y'all said that i
think it's a great caesar salad
oh
right
two weak buds oh my god there's no meat
it's just two buns and you just got it
you just put this your sandwich spread
in the middle
do you have something that you want to
try to heighten that
all i can think of is it's not a really
it's not going to be a great feel like a
theme park food but like i can think of
like groots
fiber cereal um
it's just wood it looks like wood but
it's good for your colon
i don't know this is for the elderly
guests that come
and it's just like i my motility is not
too good today
both of our meals could depending
yeah i mean i don't know if you want
bran before you get your uh
salad tossed i don't know if that's uh
but i made it worse
oh god oh well that's all right i gotta
get the point here as much as i love
uh magnificent i gotta give the point to
thunderbolt toss salad thank you you
know what i got
100. it was
that's why i've given it to you you
earned it
if my math is correct i still think uh
jay i believe you have won
this episode
[Laughter]
[Laughter]
us to say goodbye but i want to thank
all three of our guests a big
congratulations to jay washington
and congrats to us for enjoying your
company this episode yes
thank you for coming on you were
fantastic thank you for having me
it was always a pleasure man i've always
been wanting to do this for a while
seriously and
this was as much fun as i expected it to
be
well we're glad we're glad we lived up
to your expectations and be sure to
check out uh
everything jay is doing he's a very
funny comedian uh
sometimes uh a professional wrestler as
well or is it professional or is it what
to
define what wrestling when they pay me
as professional when it's not
just running around some types of
wrestling boots that's just
yeah that's so cool though uh and then
also check out uh the uh the blurts in
the hood show as well
also thank you to jess clements jess
where can we see you
lulu underscore clemens everywhere lulu
clemens
team jacob on gaming stuff thank you for
joining us
and mt as well empty you have uh some
exciting
stuff coming out on the channel new
rockstars this week you want to tease
any of it oh it's just some you know
eternals related stuff maybe with thanos
you know what i'm saying
oh just talking about some thanos
connections you know
um but yeah you can follow me at
mastertainment on twitter or
you know instagram wherever so yeah well
that's it for this episode of rogue
theory thank you for watching support
our many great merch options at new york
stars merch.com
follow me at eavos follow new rockstar
subscribe here on youtube and we will
see you next week
bye bye everybody
[Music]
you